الاجواء حماسيه جدا وصل الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان قبل قليل وبدا بخطابه امام هذا
التجمع الانتخابي الاخير قبل الصمت
الانتخابي الساعه السادسه مساء دعنا نشاهد
الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان وهو يتحدث اتى وهو
بدا بحديثه عن قاسم باشا هذه المنطقه التي
ولد فيها ونحن هنا في منطقه تقسيم التي
تعرف بباي اوغلو تركيا هذه هذا الخطاب هو
الاخير اذا له قبل ان يصلي صلاه المغرب في
ايه صوفيا كان قبله تحدث سليمان سويلم
وزير الداخليه من على نفس المنصه اضافه
الى رئيس حزب العداله والتنميه في اسطنبول
عثمان نوري كباس هناك تركيز كبير على
الجانب الامريكي في الموضوع لانه سليمان
سويلم قال قبل قليل علانيه ان بايدن
سينزعج غدا عندما يرى نتائج الفوز فوز
اردوغان وعوده الى ولايه جديده في السلطان
هؤلاء الحشود يحييون رجب طيب اردوغان الان
وهو على المنصه طبعا هذه الانتخابات هي
انتخابات ليست بالعاديه بالنسبه اليه هو
تعود على الفوز في العشرين عاما الاخيره
ولكن هذه المره المعركه قاسيه جدا امام
معارضه موحده على طاوله سداسيه امام
معارضه مختلفه التوجهات والاحزاب هذه
المره الاولى التي يواجه فيها هذا الامر
خاصه بعد خسارته لرئاسه بلديه خساره الحزب
لرئاسه بلديه اسطنبول وانقره في عام 2019
الرئيس اردوغان لا يزال على المنصه يحيي
الجمهور يحيي جمهور حزب العداله والتنميه
الذين تجمعوا
لرؤيته ومتحمسون جدا يغنون الاغاني
التابعه للحزب وهو يغادر الان هذه المنصه
طبعا نعرف يمشي بتتاقل نعرف انه عمره 69
عاما وتعرض لوعكه صحيه اثناء الحمله
الانتخابيه اضطر على اثرها لقطع برنامجها
الانتخابي لثلاثه ايام ولكن اعاده كل
المعلومات وقالت ان صحته جيده وهو يتابع
على كل المرشح الاكبر عمره اكبر ب 74 عاما
اي كمالك هناك
كثير من المواطنين المصرين على ان ينتقلوا
الى المنصه لكي يحيوا الرئيس ويسلم عليه
والامن يحاول ان يتعامل مع الموضوع هناك
الاف من الاتراك يتجمعون هنا في وسط تقسيم
في وسط باي اوبلوس لمشاهده الرئيس هذه هي
الاجواء الان من هذه المنطقه حيث
يبدو انه لا يزال الرئيس اردوغان موجودا
واعتلى المنصه لعله سيتابع في خطاباته
الانتخابيه يحاولون استغلال
هذه هذا البرنامج الانتخابي يعني الى اخر
لحظه حتى السادسه مساء بعد نحو ساعتين
عندما ندخل حيز الصمت الانتخابي على فكره
بالمناسبه خالد كانت هناك المعطيات بشان
اعتقال نحو 15
من هؤلاء الذين توعدت وزاره الداخليه
ومديره الامن بالقاء القبض عليهم ممن
نشروا معلومات مزيفه عن محرم انجي المرشح
الرئاسي الذي انسحب من السباق وكان محور
الجدل في اليومين الماضيين في هذه
الانتخابات الرئاسيه هذه اخر المعلومات
التي يعني عندنا من اسطنبول من مقر الحمله
الانتخابيه للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان
وسنتابع طبعا في رصه المشهد اولا باول حتى
وصول هذه الانتخابات الى مرحلتها الاخيره
والاعلان عن الفائز من سيكون الرئيس
الثالث عشر للجمهوريه التركيه شهر ماذا
يركز او على مدى يركز اردوغان في في خطابه
الخير وكيف يمكن النظر ايضا الى حظوظه
يعني مع ارتفاع مستوى الفقر التضخم
البطاله ايضا تراجع ملف الحريات وحقوق
الانسان كما يقول الكثير من
الماضيه
هذه نقطه ضعف اساسيه عنده اي موضوع
الاقتصاد ويحاولون ان يركزوا عليه كثيرا
في كل خطاباتهم كل من استمعت اليهم في هذه
الخطابات قبل قليل من مسؤوليه حزب العداله
والتنميه والدوله يتحدثون عن الاقتصاد عن
خلق الوظائف هو وعد بسته ملايين وظيفه
سيسلقها اضافه الى شان الحريات حتى
اردوغان تحدث عنه بالمناسبه المعارضه تلوم
بموضوع الحريات وبموضوع الاقتصاد ويردون
بادانا رفعنا الحد الادنى للاجور وباننا
سنقلق الوظائف وباننا حولنا تركيا الى
دوله متقدمه اما في موضوع الحريات اتعرف
ماذا قال اردوغان في احد خطابات وقال انا
نفسي تعرضت للسجن وهو فعلا تعرض للسجن على
اثر قراءته احدى القصائد هو يقول انها
تدرس تدرس في كتب المدارس ولكنها كانت
يعني فيها تلميحات فيما يتعلق بالجيش
ويقول ان يعني سكنات انماذننا هي التوكنات
بهذا المعنى الذي يجمع بين ما هو اسلامي
وديني وبين ما هو عسكري وهذه نقطه جدليه
ونقطه فيها الكثير من الحساسيه في تركيا
خاصه مع حزب يعني اسلام يتولى السلطه
محافظ بعد عقود من سيطره العلمانيه على
تركيا تلك العلمانيه التي يقودها الطرف
الاخر الان وهو كمال كليتش مرشح تحالف
الامه الذي يجمع كل تلك الاحزاب حوله حتى
غير العلمانيين استطاع ان يجمعهم كما قلنا
انه استطاع جذب بعض المحافظين وحتى حزب
الشعوب الديمقراطي الكردي الذي لم يرشح
يعني مرشحا خاصه انما دعمك في الرئاسه هذه
معركه حاليه وطيس ستحدد معالم تركيا
للمرحله المقبله بعد فتره سيطره عليها حزب
العداله والتنميه 2019 عندما فاز اكرم
امام اوبلو ومن سوريا واش في رئاسه بلديه
اسطنبول وانقره هل تلك الانتخابات على
مفارقه بدايه التغيير هل كانت كذلك بالفعل
هل سيفوز اردوغان في الرئاسه من الجوله
الاولى او من الجوله الثانيه ويخسر
البرلمان او العكس كله كلها اسئله مفتوحه
بانتظار الساعات الاخيره هناك الكثير من
الامور التي يمكن ان تحدد رغم الصمت
الانتخابي التي يمكن ان تحدد اكثر في مزاج
الناخر ولكن بدون شك كما تفضلت خالد
الاقتصاد يبقى عاملا اساسيا
جيوب المواطن هي الاهم بالنسبه اليه قبل
اي شيء اخر اضافه الى مواضيع الحريات التي
تحدثنا عنها لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات